this is a review of game 9 of the 10
games that were released on December 6
the 2017 of the match that went down
between Google's acquired company and
deep mind and their chess-playing
software alpha zero as it took on the
world's strongest chess engine stock
fish and this is what happened we had d4
and before you think okay yet another
Queen's Indian defense finally stock
fish decides he's had enough of the
abuse in the Queen's Indian and he's
gonna switch it up with e6 if you
haven't seen our video reviews of Game
three Game five and Game eight and
you're wondering wait I want to see
those abuse of Queen's Indians go ahead
and click on the links here included
with the video or just google and find
it you'll see our video reviews of
course you know this is gonna be one of
my favorite videos to date because it
was a French loves me a good French and
after d5 we get main line theory
alpha zero playing Knight to c3 Knight
f6 v 5 9 ft 7 and with f4 we are
officially in what is a mainline French
defense call it what you want a
classical a Stein ants Bob's your uncle
doesn't matter after c5 we have Knight
f3 and we are in a position that has
been played hundreds and thousands of
times so not a hundred thousand but
hundreds and thousands and in these
games just about every strong
grandmaster plays the approach as black
but you really want to build on this
tension the moves such as Knight to c6
has been played
I think north of 7000 times in this
position the move a six is very common
also to sort of guard the b5 square in a
very typical French move of course moves
like Queen to b6 are also possible
Bishop to e7 is also possible any of
these would have been mainline theory
and so here we see stockfish very first
by taking on d4 but what's more is that
alpha zeros evaluation of White's best
approach here is different than what's
most often been played c5 takes d4 is a
move has been played but almost always
met by the immediate recapture of the
pawn as it makes the most sense but
alpha 0 plays the move Knight to b5
interesting stuff based mainly on the
point that is is actually really easy to
understand
if you could choose which night you want
on d4 it probably would be the c3 night
mainly because you want to use that
three suite C 3 square excuse me for the
pawn with the pawn on c3 supporting the
knight which in turn sort of keeps the
position closed and allows you to focus
your efforts on a King side attack very
very common stuff and a French pawn
structure it makes sense that you would
want to take back on d4 with the c3
Knight why go out of your way to take
with the f3 Knight and then have to move
this knight anyway later just to get c3
this is a typical idea that is actually
played in some variations of the French
win or so to see Knight to b5 played by
alpha 0 suddenly you look at it with
fresh eyes I guess and you say yeah it
makes a lot of sense that this would be
a pretty sound approach here from white
and now after Bishop before check we are
officially in novelty territory 19 p5
had only been played one other time but
it was met by him the move Knight to c6
so here Bishop to b4 check was played by
stockfish and after Bishop to d2 he
realizes he doesn't actually want to
give up that dark square Bishop based
mainly on obvious reasons that if that
Bishop is traded the d6 square becomes a
real problem with that Knight on b5
still standing so instead he plays
Bishop to c5 his ideas are to make sure
that he can hold on to that d6 square
and only only develop the the rest of
the Queen side once there's no longer
really this threat of the knight coming
into d6
but if we're taking a step back and
saying ok we're officially in
unchartered waters yes it's a pawn
structure we're very familiar with right
this is a wedge setup which basically
means you have a normally a closed pawn
chain where the middle pawn has been
replaced by a piece that's the
positional or pawn structure definition
of a wedge a pawn chain where the middle
pawn the base pawn has been replaced by
a minor piece either a knight or a
bishop the advantages of the wedge
structure is that often a minor piece in
the middle of this pawn structure is is
more active than upon right obviously
minor pieces can do more than pawns can
the disadvantage is that without the
pawn sort of holding that chain together
right in the center your lead pawn this
weaker often there's also open diagonals
because of that so this is just some
positional background on a structure
that is it's very common in the French
but I think white has reached an ad
version of that here white plays the
move a c3 completing exactly the wedge
that I've just been talking about and
with the time he's gained with B for the
lost time by the bishop you start to
like White's French pretty simply put
after a 5 B 5 we capture on d4 but
liking White's French or not it's still
a pretty I guess pretty standard French
position where the the pollen structures
become symmetrical we know White's gonna
have a space advantage with the d4 and
e5 ponds hoping to launch that into a
King side attack but we know that if
black eliminates the dark square bishop
he's got long-term potential of the dark
squares being weak and certainly that
means that white has to find a safe
place to put the King out of the way of
all of these potentially weak dark
squares right that that's what we would
anticipate that it means
well apparently alpha 0 has something
else in mind
brace yourself for the devil exclam King
takes d2 right
he puts the King on d2 and says actually
the safest approach I can take toward
holding down my pawn structure and
keeping that center closed is to use the
King and put that guy right on III where
once I don't have to worry about the
center pawns my other pieces can
actually get involved in helping the
attack be even more effective and again
it's it's just a shocker honestly it's
it's so simple and so clear that white
would obviously want to attack on the
King side in the French and of course
keeping these pawns protected the center
closed is always a key part of doing
that but using the King in this way it
feels like a move magnus carlsen would
come up with and and play and indeed
it's a move that once you see it makes a
ton of sense Bishop to d7 the King comes
to e3 and we're gonna see over the next
several moves white is as aggressive as
you can pretty much ever be in a French
because all the pieces are primed and
ready the Queen swings over to g1 black
has to put the bishop back on f8 to
guard the g7 pawn note that moves like
g6 are probably just met by Bishop takes
g6 followed by an absolutely crushing
mating attack by white which is why we
see Bishop f8 natural expansions are
still going to lead to all kinds of
pressure on the Queen side but usually
the way that these frenches break down
and this is similar to
you see a lot of her chronic have played
these positions before anybody from the
Anatoly Karpov school of chess using
both sides principle of two weaknesses
now we're gonna go poke at the C file to
make sure that these pieces can't change
their efforts to totally focusing on my
king side pressure the next few moves
make a lot of sense with that White's
gonna double rooks infiltrate into the
c7 square and force black to deal with
that matter you do nothing here moves
like Bishop takes g6 with the knight
coming in to g5 the other rooks coming
in you just get the feeling it's only a
matter of time before a lethal
breakthrough happens so black plays rook
to c8 and what's amazing is we've
actually been letting stockfish think
here you see the evaluation bar on the
left side of the board and it still
thinks black is okay here
black is not okay here this position
after takes c8 and rook c6 you're only
gonna see the pressure increase here for
white and eventually it's again it's the
horizon effect where White knows that
these pieces will put themselves on on
squares that will be good enough for a
lethal breakthrough do I actually see
what that lethal breakthrough is right
now no I don't but it's going to happen
due to blacks lack of options right the
lack of ways that black can improve the
position and again that's the difference
between how alpha zero was approaching
these things or how me as your human
commentator in this case is translating
what alpha zero was thinking and and
he's doing it in such a super accurate
way that it's that's honestly a joy
after Bishop e7 note that of course
we're not taking here because there's no
reason to allow King c7 although
probably if you put the rook on d6 and
gave it up for the dark square Bishop
freeing up the e5 square I'm not sure
it's so simple but okay no reason to do
it alpha zero agrees and backs up the
rook and after the move King to d7 92 g5
Bishop to e7 is where things get just
get super fun if you want to pause the
video and try to guess that every guess
the move that sort of brings brings to
the forefront and highlights what we've
been saying was going to happen it's
only a matter of time before that lethal
breakthrough takes place because of
blacks lack of options you can do that
but too late I've already given you a
chance to pause it we're continuing
Bishop takes g6 at first you think you
can't do this and that's why the
evaluation bar slides down because can't
I don't have to take back which of
course
would allow mate right you can take e6
and then a million things I think just
Queen takes b6 is probably mating a
couple Knight of seven wins so but
obviously stock fish didn't have that
plan he had the plan to take on g5 first
right that's how black is maintaining
his edge here unfortunately no the Queen
just takes back giving up the bishop in
a way that is honestly mind-blowing at
first you just give up the piece
straight up and follow with f5 and you
realize that black still has no moves
the bishop on b7 is completely useless
taking on on f5 would allow the move
Queen to f6 and there's no way to deal
with Queen d6 mate without the rook on
h8 falling taking with the G pawn would
allow the move Queen to g7 and again the
position is just completely collapsing
so stock fish played rook to g8 makes
sense but the Queen is gonna continue to
interm her inchworm her way in to take
advantage of the dark squares she plays
the move Queen to h6 now the threat of
queen h7 check is pretty lethal you
can't block on e7 because rook c7 will
take that King away and the Queen will
fall really there was nothing black
could do here and again a human being
can see that this position is collapsing
Queen Queen up to f7 makes the most
sense you have to try to stop the
obvious threats and see if Y can come up
with more and again this is where it
gets even more fun f6 white is playing
the position for the long-term factors
that black is never going to be able to
coordinate due to a bishop that is
blocked in if this isn't a classically
bad Bishop and the French defense I
don't know what is and the fact that the
f6 pawn combined with Future Passed
pawns are gonna be enough nothing like
seeing a position where we're reminded
of those those principles in chests the
tiglon Petrosian and everyone we've
we've our forefathers have taught us
which is your square control and ability
to create threats is really who's better
the reason we value material and give
them our dogmatic evaluations of the
bishop is worth three points the rook is
worth five points right the reason we do
that is because what you're assessing is
in an open board without any other sort
of forms of controversy the rooks
potential power we evaluate is about
worth five points and that open board
where he's really at his best staying
with the bishop the knight whatever
right so all those things are true and
I'm not challenging the point values but
what we see is that access to square
just squares and your ability to make
threats and eventually win the game is
the reason why you want those pieces
that's the reason we gave them their
value is because we know that they can
help us achieve our ultimate goal of
using threats to win material and
eventually checkmate win the game so
it's fascinating when you see sacrifices
work in that way and really fun because
you see that square control in this case
the dark squares the C file is white
White's winning the material is
irrelevant so the next few moves are
played lights playing a bit of tickle
mainly because black can't do anything
anyway now the queen is gonna flip the
script and try to infiltrate over here
into lethal squares that's gonna force
black's hand and make him have to trade
queens you're thinking okay again but
isn't a queen trade good right at least
you know lar getting mated and aren't I
not up a piece yeah you are but you
don't have enough time rook g1
highlights that there's no there's no
activity battle here right you can't try
to give up the the G pawn for the H pawn
because I'm giving check and cleaning
the pawn before you know what hits you
right so here black plays b3 a stockfish
move that isn't gonna do much the pawns
gonna fall no matter what but the main
thing is even once this bishop comes all
the way over to guard g6 which makes
sense it's exactly what you need to get
the rook to come to the hh8 square it
doesn't matter because after the move
rook a one let's give it a line if Rick
h8 is played we're gonna see that again
there is no activity battle here white
is breaking through too quickly and with
too much on the plate rook takes a5 that
after the h4 pawn Falls we're gonna see
moves like rook hey check the King come
in to c5 and even on things like rook h1
check in the King infiltrates and black
is simply running out of time so after
rook a1 black black didn't go for the
activity battle which is which is gonna
lose he played the move King c7 a5 comes
in anyway and again as the board opens
up on both sides a similar story is
being written that Square control and
these threats are is what matters and
white eventually brings the king to e7
the bishop is either falling or allowing
the f7 pawn to push and once again we
have an amazing display of simply
fascinating technique a stockfish throws
away one more pawn just like a computer
would before throwing in the towel
against alpha zero so if you haven't
watched all four videos yet and this is
your first experience of what the
amazing feat was that this
machine learning Organic learning teach
yourself AI has done from deep mine
again a Google acquired company then you
need to back up and watch the other
videos if you've seen all four videos
then you know kind of what to expect in
our next video here mind blowing stuff
took place and the chest world was
indeed turned upside down by alpha zero
we're seeing things that make stockfish
look like an uncoordinated amateur like
we've never seen before and that is what
we saw here once again in game 9 please
stay tuned
buckle your buckle your seat belts and
check out game 10 coming your way
shortly